New York Governor Andrew Cuomo brushing
off criticism over nursing home deaths
due to Cove in nineteen it's all
politics they want to attack the
Democrats for nursing home deaths it's
the same MO just distract you know
create a shiny object to take attention
off they what they don't want you to
focus on but some argue the numbers show
it's not just about politics as deaths
in nursing home and assisted care
facilities accounted for 26% of all
coronavirus deaths in the state joining
me now to discuss Fox News medical
contributor and author of make America
healthy again a fantastic book that you
all should check out dr. Nicole Sapphire
doctor sapphire welcome to the show as
always so what do you make of Cuomo's
comments here I mean it's pretty
outrageous from where I'm sitting for
him to just say oh this is all political
you know has nothing to do with me and
my decision-making and point the blame
elsewhere
well Jedediah I think it's actually
quite comical that a politician is
saying it's all political because let's
talk about first of all Janis Dean our
own Janis Dean has been one of the most
vocally present in this matter and she
doesn't have a political bone in her
body so it is extremely inflammatory for
president Cuomo to come out and say that
a president Governor Cuomo to come out
and say that here's the thing Jenna
value so this really highlights a very
important point that we have in the
United States and that is our nursing
home care we have seen over and over
again every time a hurricane or natural
disaster is hit the nursing homes have
suffered and they have really struggled
to keep their patients safe especially
when it comes to Coba 19 this is a
highly transmissible virus and this
population in particular is extremely
susceptible to severe effects of this
virus so in March when these orders went
out saying that nursing homes had to in
fact take Ovid positive patients back
into the nursing homes that really
created many issues now the federal
guidelines they're having this
tit-for-tat right now almost saying well
he was following federal guidelines in
the CIMA bærum is saying no you didn't
the truth is those federal guidelines
said nursing homes had to take them back
if they were prepared
able to care for those patients and
that's a very big caveat meaning they
needed to have the staffing they needed
to have the PPE and they really made it
a step-down unit or an area where just
those covin positive patients were the
problem with this virus
it is highly transmissible very high are
not meaning that it's very contagious
and in the elderly they tend to have
viral shedding longer than the rest of
the population so they stay infectious
longer than say maybe you or I would
Jedediah and that's probably one of the
biggest problems here the one thing I
mean that we knew from the beginning
that seemed to be consistent when so
many other things with respect to this
virus were not consistent was that there
was a vulnerable population that people
who were older were more susceptible so
it makes no sense to me that a governor
would follow that directive and it seems
to me also Nicole I don't know if you
can weigh in on this nursing homes
around the country didn't necessarily
have this problem there were a lot of
nursing homes in other states that were
able to protect their patients
so for cuomo to turn around and say well
this is all about trump this is all
about directors from the cdc those
directives were consistent everywhere
that's not what happened in New York
well there is a difference though I have
to say Jedediah when it comes to the
Northeast versus the rest of the country
you have to remember that we had
significantly more cases in the
beginning and I can tell you from
personal experience our hospital systems
were overflowing with Kovac patients
there was no way shape or form that they
would have been able to keep all those
patients in the hospital especially if
they only had mial infections at that
time so it was necessary to get some of
those patients that didn't require
inpatient hospitalization out of the
hospital it's also good for their safety
as well because there are such issues of
keeping people in the hospital for
prolonged periods of time
that being said Jedediah with that
directive knowing that they needed to
get the elderly out of the hospital into
nursing homes they needed to make a
priority that those nursing homes could
care for those patients and that is what
did not happen yeah thank you so much
Nicole for yer haps use the comfort ship
perhaps use another vehicle or another
mechanism that didn't involve the most
vulnerable population which everyone was
saying protect the elderly people over a
certain age are
more at risk for serious infection
madness and if nothing else he should
take some responsibility thank you we
got to go but thanks so much for being
here